week nine most important match-ups
you've got a trivia question for me oh
wait i do have the trivia question for
you hold on a second here where where is
it uh
wait where is it pete is in the sheets
oh okay okay i was looking on my phone
usually you texted all right tom brady
and drew brees are obviously top two all
time in td passes we talked about that
what qb's were top two back in 2001 when
brady and brees each threw their first
career td passes so wow yes you know won
dan marino's one right dan marino's one
who's the other then the question is who
was hanging in at number two brett favre
hadn't played long enough so it would
have been it would have been john elway
no
no man you couldn't even get your old
quarterback you couldn't even figure out
of his friend tarkin team no way he
didn't have more than tarkington i don't
think so nope i think he was i remember
but
i remember when targeting got that
record i think it was 290. that was that
was like
i was unreasonably happy about that
and and i was pissed i remember being
pissed when mourinho beat him so maybe i
should have gotten that one right now
yeah you should have gone i just thought
i thought elway had more because i was
retired by that i just thought elway had
more as well all right you get the first
pick all right oh we never caught him
yep elbow i never caught him um
i think i'm going to start off with um
this colt's front versus lamar jackson
that's the one where i'm going to go
first this colts defense is number three
in football and run defense deforest
buckner's been amazing darius leonard
special one of the best middle
linebackers in football i mean they've
been physically dominant but they
haven't played a team like this quite
yet as far as the baltimore ravens who
also are physically dominant and you
know cause some issues of what they do
with lamar jackson i think this is i'm
interested in one because i want to see
how baltimore bounces back after last
week they did a lot of good things but
lost the football game and you know the
colts
the last time they played a real good
running team in like the cleveland
browns the browns had their way with
them that's really about the only team
that has but i would i guess we're not
sure how good the colts are too and i
think this is gonna be something where
okay here's a little bit more of a feel
for how legit they are are they like a
true super bowl contender or just a
play-off type caliber type team and
that's why i'm excited to see this match
up this week 265 rushing yards against
the steelers last week with jk dobbins
gus edwards and lamar jackson mark
ingram didn't practice yesterday and
they're going to realize sooner than
later if they haven't already they don't
need mark ingram next year and i love
mark ingram but he plays a position
where he's susceptible to that and i
think it's going to be dobbins and
edwards and jackson next year running
the ball for the ravens all right for me
and look we've already talked about the
drew brees tom brady angle they're never
on the field together i'm more
fascinated by
the
buccaneers receivers and tight ends yeah
against the saints linebackers and
defensive backs right because antonio
brown is going to play chris gobin we
don't know yet mike evans is healthy
gronk is gronk again good luck new
orleans saints trying to slow that
attack down i can't wait to see that
match up on sunday night even though i
have a feeling it's not going to go well
for the saints yeah i mean i'm excited
to see it too i am you know just the the
match-up of uh dennis allen versus bruce
arians and byron leforch and what he
does will he be
as bold as he's been all year and take
these chances of playing aggressive
man-to-man and do that against this
group in tampa bay you know that's what
would scare me
uh tampa can rush the passer and of
course it's hard to match up against
them across the board and the saints
just have a few plays every game where
you just go why
you know you're doing well why did you
have to go for the jugular right here
did you have to like truly decapitate
them you know you're still dominating
like what what why and uh that that's
where i just think the saints will have
to readjust this week i don't think they
can play that style of football i don't
you know their best cover corner is
genoris jenkins marshawn lattimore has
been struggle i mean struggleville and
that's where i find it hard to believe
that they'll be able to match up and
play man-to-man all right my next one
i'm gonna go to brian flores
versus uh kyler murray i think that's
the one i'm looking forward to too
that's a sneaky
really intriguing game this weekend at 4
25. i mean it's the best game at 40 25
this week i mean it's definitely better
than the steelers cowboys we know how
that's going to end but you know with
miami this you know resurgence here of
their football team how good they look
young talent he coaches well he's got
good game plans about just about anybody
he plays i mean he's shut down shanahan
and mcveigh so far can he shut down
kyler murray and cliff kingsbury you
know i'm excited to see how he
approaches that whole thing with spies
and containing him in the pocket and all
that so very exciting to me in that
matchup
yeah absolutely i mean it's one thing to
befuddle jared goff but good luck with
kyler murray because he's so nimble and
everything you try potentially is going
to fail you can't even run a scout team
when you're dealing with kyle murray
because once you get out there and see
kyler murray there's no one else like
him right now in the national football
league next one for me
i'm gonna go with
the viking secondary which is completely
gutted
against matthew stafford who can't
practice this week ooh he's he can show
up sunday and play the vikings had three
corners that did not practice yesterday
they had another corner who was limited
in practice
i can't wait to see how this plays out
because i assume that the lions will go
forward with matthew stafford even
though he hasn't practiced he's gonna i
mean this this guy has played time and
again when he's injured he's healthy so
what if i haven't practiced i'm playing
right i want to see what he does against
that viking secondary because even
though the vikings are feeling good
about themselves coming out of the last
week
that defense is still overmatched and uh
you know they got lucky they made a few
stops they had a questionable pass
interference call that should have been
made that was picked up i want to see
that match up because whoever loses this
game is done the winner still very much
alive the loser it's over yeah no uh i i
hear you there and you're right i mean
like yes the vikings won last week but
yeah you know you watched the game back
it wasn't one of those things where
you're like oh
you know they they were dominant last
week in beating green bay they never
really stopped green bay the whole day
so uh i hear you there and yes you're
you got to play matt stafford i don't
care about practice or not but uh
that'll be an interesting game all
together it really will and and and you
know kenny gallaudet is he healthy again
is he back i know he he was a little
banged up again so that'll go a long way
in that matchup to see where it goes too
all right my last pick i'm gonna go j a
versus j a
and that's my boy blue josh allen versus
jamal adams because i think that is
gonna be fun to watch
um
awesome game at one o'clock seahawks
going across the country against the
buffalo bills jamal adams it sounds like
he's going to be back in full effect and
i would think he is going to be the guy
that will be responsible for josh allen
a lot i think they'll blitz him thinking
he'll track this guy down he'll get him
down that way so i really think a lot of
the game could come down to yeah bills
will make plays do all that seattle let
up plays we know that
but seattle in every big game always
creates one or two turnovers with the
chaos they create and jamal adams will
be a big part of that and i think a lot
of the times they're gonna find ways to
blitz to where he's free and now it's
gonna be okay can you tackle this big
soldier josh allen one on one which a
lot of people can't and uh he sacks him
a few times or hits him as he's throwing
things like that i would go oh seattle's
gonna win the game josh allen escapes
and doesn't have those type of plays i'd
go uh oh i'd watch out buffalo might
play the game so that that'll be a fun
matchup
by the way gallaudet did not practice on
wednesday with a lingering hip in three
so that's a question mark as well for
the lions last one for me we talked
about this earlier but i i i'm intrigued
by it
with the bears losing two in a row yeah
and they played the saints much more
closely than they played the rams the
week before the titans reeling the one
loss against the steelers turned into a
second loss against the bengals that
titan's defensive line against the bears
offensive line injuries and covet issues
for the bears ol
and the titans can't get
to the quarterback and jadavian clowney
still with the knee injury can the
titans get a pass rush on nick falls
because nick fole's the kind of guy look
if you don't get in his face
if you don't rattle him if you don't
start hitting him he's going to make
something happen down the field so the
titans have got to get to him or they're
going to get into maybe a shootout with
the chicago bears chris i i'm interested
to see how that game goes too you know
you can flip it around i'm excited to
see derek henry go against that bears
run 7-2 how does that play out you know
it's a sneaky good matchup in that
football game a lot of little different
angles to look at so uh good job good
job of you i won the draft but wait wait
hang in there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports